good morning believe nation it's Evan my
one word is believe and I believe that
you have something special that when you
unleash it it will be able to change the
world so to help you on your journey
today's message is write it all down
over to you Joe Rogan write down
everything you want to do I don't mean
crazy like I'm gonna be the Prince of
Brunei I'm gonna have a base and moon
shut up this is what I want you to do
right write down what you would like to
fix about your life and then just if
you're thirty pounds over what you want
to lose thirty pounds do it the right
way
go start eating vegetables monitor your
calories write down what you eat
exercise every day force yourself to do
it say you're the general the brain is
the general the troops of the body the
troops don't want to listen but you'll
will you listen and you get up and you
do it and then you get to write it down
and if you don't write it down you don't
eat you don't you don't jerk off you
don't shower write that down so you do
it it's like brushing your teeth it's
not something I want to brush my teeth
today what do you want you to eat the
right out of your head you dunce just do
it just do it make yourself do it and if
you do that if you write down and do
that you can change you all I'm a big
believer in writing things down I have
my goals down my big goal that I want to
accomplish but also my weekly goals and
my daily goals I wake up I know what I
have to do today because it's written
down in my Google Calendar note and I
think this is a key difference that can
really help a lot of entrepreneurs is
understanding planning versus doing I
think too many entrepreneurs are
constantly in planning mode and it's fun
to be in planning mode right you're
planning you're thinking you're dreaming
you're imagining it's gonna here's how
I'm gonna start and then we're gonna
hire this person and you keep building
this great idea I just kept getting
bigger and bigger bigger and it's
exciting you fire off the the happiness
feelings of this great idea that you're
exploding out but nothing happens until
you do right and sometimes the planning
and the seen it through the to the end
is so excited and it's so fulfilling
that then you don't even want to do it
because you already got the happiness
I'm doing that and you don't actually
want to do any of the work where most
entrepreneurs I think you're up here
with planning and
like down here in execution you got to
flip it planning is really important you
don't want to just go out and do and
hope something happens right that's not
the path to have a success so planning
is important but doing is way more
important like you got to spend way more
time on the execution versus the
planning and so this is why writing
things down really helps so when you're
in planning mode and whether it's once a
week or once a month or once a quarter
or some kind of mixture whenever you
feel your planes aren't going according
to according to plan
you create a new plan and so you okay
mundane gonna wake up and here's what
I'm gonna work on and when I look at my
Google Calendar note and I wake up and I
see Monday and here are my tasks I know
what my goal is like here's my big goal
and then I know how I'm gonna accomplish
that and then I know what I need to do
today so the planning mode is super
small on the Monday I'm just reviewing
what I need to get done and then I spend
the entire day doing executing making
tons of progress how am I able to make
three videos a day for my youtube
channel yes I have a team yes they help
me tremendously and yes we have a plan
in place right of how to structure the
day and how to film and what goes up and
content reviewing a whole system and
architecture and we constantly work to
improve that plan but it's most of the
time we're spending time doing like I am
executing Christina my editor is
executing the people on my team are
executing we're doing the work and so
you need to get out of the planning mode
and more into the execution mode and if
you don't write things down then you
stay in planning mode too much at least
I find if I woke up and I didn't know
what I was gonna do today I didn't have
a plan then I'd wake up and make a plan
right I make a plan and then I'd start
from the top again and then and I would
spend a good chunk of time planning and
not enough time actually doing and if I
did that every day then I'd be losing so
much time to planning that I would never
get as much done as I could get done so
pine is important and you need to spend
time planning and you figure out what is
your execution gameplan right good and
then most of your time 90% of your time
are spent actually doing the work and
then you come back at some point like
did this work
or did it lead to results is this the
best use of my time you can come back to
planning mode every now and then and
make some adjustments then go out and
test it again but this is where you need
to spend most your time the work they're
doing the execution the hard stuff
versus planning the thinking the
dreaming only need both pieces but you
gotta play more here and over here so
the question of the day today is I'm
curious what your habits are of writing
things down
do you write down your big goals your
little goals you have daily to-do lists
what do you do to write things down that
helps your business move forward or is
there new habit that you're going to
start after watching this video let me
know leave it down in the comments below
really looking forward to hearing your
thoughts I also want to give a quick
shout out to Alex Smith from odd angry
shot Alex thank you so much for bringing
up a copy of my book your one word means
a lot to remain and I hope you enjoy the
read so thank you guys again for
watching I believe in you I hope you
continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your one word is much love and
I'll see you guys again tomorrow morning
for another shot of espresso
[Music]
my infrastructure what I wanted to see
myself I wrote I wrote I write
everything down and I see everything so
I got books and books and books from
years that now I go back and pull out
and I'm like wow you said this a no.9 no
and now you're living it you also so you
plane yeah okay and you see it and you
see it and that's one thing I share with
guys I'm like listen write down your
vision write it you know let your
subconscious mind be the leader of you
you know I'm saying trust it because
what you think is your subconscious mind
ultimately what you're gonna live music
and that's that's when God says write
division he said make it plain he didn't
save me prior to 5000 race hey he just
said write it make it plain so you can
see it so you can visually see where you
want to go in your next steps and so for
me I did that a lot and I still do it if
you write your goals down it makes all
the difference Harvard did a study in
1973 they took the graduating class and
asked how many of them had goals a
hundred percent of them had goals well
they asked how many had written down
their goals upon graduation only five
percent of the class had in 1993 twenty
years later they followed up with the
class they found that the five percent
that had written down their goals 20
years prior upon graduating were worth
more financially than the other 95
percent of the class put together so I
have always written my goals down about
what I wanted to achieve and I really
attribute a lot to that and then aim
high
it's really true so the most important
thing you can do is plan your day
preferably the night before sit down
with a piece of paper and write down
everything that you have to do the
coming day it should be the last thing
you do at the end of the day now if for
any reason you don't do this then the
first thing you do in the morning
before you check your email your phone
calls newspapers first thing you do in
the morning is make a list of everything
that you have to do that day once you
have a list you have a track to run on
writing down a list clarifies your
thinking writing down a list forces you
to think at a higher level if you are
working from a list you increase your
productivity and output by 25
percent the first day all successful
people work from lists and all
successful people with regard to their
projects were from check lists a
checklist is a list of everything
organized in sequence and you go down
the checklist